plaisir cette cuillère c'est une
nouvelle responsabilité pour la bénévole
diane cusson setchine au fresnoy et des
résidents comme roland fleury à
s'alimenter
une tâche autrefois réservé aux employés
qui sont aujourd'hui trop peu nombreux
on note des difficultés au niveau du
personnel on a une pénurie de personnel
quand même importante comme partout au
québec le manque de personnel
alourdissement de la clientèle nous
montrent vrai mec il y préposés ont de
moins en moins de fait depuis octobre
des bénévoles aident les préposés pour
nourrir des résidents dans le cadre de
projets pilotes ça le pen
première marque des gens lévis dans
l'image du show ok c'est une des choses
et ça raccourci le teint pour dîner ou
le super discussion participe aussi
parfois au nettoyage de table parce
qu'elle arrive pas et des foyers tenant
à 38,6 ils viennent de finir ça n'a pas
de bon sens ils ont vraiment besoin
deuil
si on continue avec les patients qui ont
des trous avec la déglutition pourtant
l'aide aux repas fait partie de la
formation des futurs préposé prévenu
c'est l'étouffement s'assurer que la
personne manches suffisamment surtout si
les diabétiques s'assurer que la diète
elle est bien respectée le syndicat
pense qu'il ne faut pas trop en mettre
sur les épaules des bénévoles exemple
une personne cette hausse
on ne peut pas agir ça prend absolument
la préposée la préposée ou une
infirmière fermé ardilla le csld en est
conscient et offre une formation à ces
bénévoles en plus les bénévoles alimente
les gens que dans les aires communes
jamais dans les chambres dont furent
toujours du personnel sont prêts à
intervenir
l'expérience pourrait être étendue
ailleurs dans le centre du québec
c'est que l'aide l'alimentation serait
apprécié des résidents et des bénévoles
c'est un lien ici les gens sont ça se
plaint pas beaux yeux beau sourire haïti
franchement quand j'aurai plein de moins
non moi je cherchais un réconfort ici
david gêne-t-il radio canada
mon frère